walking away knowing that was it based
on your audition or was it just that
they were looking for somebody with a
totally different oh you never know
that's the thing you never know unless
like you said someone's nice enough to
have been in the room of tell you flat
out the best you can do is just sort of
you know you have to develop your own
mantra and system for that it you know
you're enough it's not it's not you it's
just the part that's the thing so
sometimes you walk in and there's
something about you that just doesn't
fit you could be very very well suited
for anything but this particular thing
they need someone a little taller a
little shorter a little more brown hair
and a little less hair you know it could
literally be that something that small
or they need someone who isn't as a
little bit more confident a little less
confident I mean whenever you can always
pretend and fake I mean there's a lot of
actors who can do anything I mean I'm
not mine actually I shouldn't say a lot
there's something I can do anything like
Joaquin Phoenix Daniel day-lewis and the
audience can do anything there's no
limit but most of us we have who we are
and that is about eighty percent of
everything where we're going to do
because that's who you are and it's
going to come out and that's what they
want to see anyone they want truth and
the best way to be truthful is to be you
so sometimes your own truth isn't
necessarily the truth they're looking
for and and then you just have to make
peace of that and just know hey not the
hearing know is ninety-five percent of
the job and even that you're not going
to hear no you're just not gonna hear
anything so that's why you know when
you're talking about the feedback um
with what we're doing with our these
auditions as I really feel it's
important then we try with the place
we're using that we give valid feedback
and not something like it was a pleasure
seeing him but actually say it's like
you know we enjoyed the energy that came
out of this though we felt that there
was blah blah blah blah whatever would
be you know so I think cuz it's so rare
that actors actually good feedback
that's the thing it's like super rare
and I wish we could get a lot more of it
because you don't improve with that
yeah so so not just hey it was wonderful
because that's the worst thing you can
ever get be like thank you that was
great thank you very much and it's like
don't tell me it was great if it's not
great but if it was great that's fine
just tell me it's like that's great just
not the right kind of great for us
that's I'd prefer that over just you
know you know blown smoke in my
direction and then smiling all the way
on then the door shuts and they think
well you know so oh that's just me a lot
of people that's great I think that's
perfect this guy screwed